- You got the job though.
I was telling you this in commercial.
I love how you got your job.
You got it because of tweet, right?
- Yup. Actually...
- How did that happen?
- I didn't know how to
use Twitter back then.
I didn't understand the differences
between a retweet and a like.
Like, you know, when the
tweet actually came out,
it was actually my best
friend, Shahara Gasnabi,
still best friends with her today,
she screenshotted it and
sent it to me and was like,
"Yo, yo, yo, let's do this."
And I was was like,
"Eh, I think I wanna
take a nap right now."
- It was Mindy Kaling, right?
- Yep, Mindy's Tweet.
And I was like, "Okay,
I haven't hung out with her in a while,
let's do it."
So we went to our-
- Mindy?
- Yeah.
So I was like...
Yeah, oh, yeah, for sure.
(Kelly laughs)
- You just hadn't hung
out with her in a minute?
- Yeah, I hadn't hung out-
- Your friend.
- My friend.
So, I went with my friend
to our community library
and that's where we filmed
it off of my mom's camera.
And we were thinking, like,
"Okay, this is like to the world.
So anybody could audition
for this, right?"
- Yeah.
- So we're like, "Eh, we'll
just give it the best shot
that, you know, we got."
And here we are. (chuckles)
- [Kelly] That's crazy. I love that.